en los últimos vídeos hemos reflexionado
mucho acerca del negocio de venta de
jugo de naranja aspectos tales como lo
que es un costo total promedio un costo
variable promedio costo marginal como
sería en todos estos costos si
estuviéramos en el negocio de los jugos
de naranja bueno ahora veamos qué sucede
a nivel del mercado ahora vamos a
regresar a algunos de los conceptos que
vimos en el pasado en términos de las
curvas de oferta y demanda
ese es el mercado del jugo de naranja y
ahora vamos a dibujar las curvas de
oferta y de demanda vamos a tratar a
dibujar lo más bonito este va a ser el
precio por galón en este eje precio por
galón
y digamos que aquí está un dólar
aquí están 50 centavos
y ese es el origen no es tercero y ahora
este otro eje va a ser el de las
cantidades cantidades en galones por
semana y vamos a representar todo el
mercado de jugó así que serán millones
de galones por semana millones
y galones
por semana
y ahora los vamos a marcar en el eje 1 2
3 4 5 6 hasta ahí llegamos hasta el 6 y
vamos a simplificar algo que vimos en
los vídeos anteriores vamos a decir que
nuestra curva de la oferta para el
mercado de jugo de naranja voy a tener
cuidado aquí esta es la curva a corto
plazo en la oferta y va a lucir así esta
es la curva de la oferta de todo el
mercado de todos los productores de jugo
de naranja los cuales para producir el
primer galón de jugo van a necesitar al
parecer unos 20 centavos y el costo
incremental de cada uno de los
siguientes galones para todo el mercado
va a ir aumentando cada vez más pues se
tiene que ir más lejos para conseguir
más naranjas y esto aumenta el costo
entonces esto de aquí es la curva de la
oferta o también se puede ver como el
costo marginal la curva del costo
marginal y ahora voy a dibujar una curva
de demanda totalmente arbitraria digamos
que la curva de demanda
y así esta es nuestra demanda actual
demanda actual y a esto le voy a agregar
los precios en el cual las firmas los
proveedores del jugo de naranja lleguen
a un punto neutro en cuanto a las
ganancias o lo que es lo mismo cuando la
ganancia económica es igual a cero ahora
digamos que justo acá tenemos nuestro
precio de equilibrio este es el precio
50 centavos por galón ese es el precio o
el punto en el que la ganancia económica
es igual a 0 donde la ganancia económica
es igual a 0 pero les quiero recordar
que el que la ganancia económica sea
igual a 0 no significa que la ganancia
contable sea cero las personas pueden
estar haciendo dinero con este precio
pero se vuelve neutral en cuanto a si
deberían o no estar en este negocio la
cantidad de dinero que están haciendo es
comparable con el costo de la
oportunidad de estar haciendo otras
cosas así que cuando digo que la
ganancia económica es igual a cero a
veces se le llama esto la ganancia
normal es el precio en el que la gente
está neutral en cuanto a si deberían
cerrar este negocio y comenzar a uno
nuevo cuando se tiene una ganancia
económica positiva más persona
a querer entrar en este mercado y cuando
tenemos una ganancia económica negativa
pues significa que las personas van a
elegir que esos gastos fijos en equipo y
personal invertirlos en otro negocio y
salirse de éste así que este es el punto
del que hablamos ahora analicemos un par
de escenarios digamos que un artículo de
investigación es publicado y en ese
artículo por cualquier razón dice que
las naranjas son malas para su salud por
cualquier razón que sea cuando sale ese
artículo diciendo que las naranjas son
malas para la salud qué va a pasar con
la demanda bueno pues en cualquier
precio dado la demanda va a bajar en
cualquier precio la demanda va a bajar y
la nueva curva de demanda puede lucir
así ahora en el corto plazo podemos
encontrar un nuevo precio de equilibrio
y una cantidad de equilibrio ese era el
punto de equilibrio anterior y de la
manera en lo que lo puse resultaba que
la ganancia económica en este punto era
igual a cero y esta era nuestra antigua
cantidad de equilibrio un poquito más
arriba que los 3 millones de galones por
semana y ahora tenemos un precio de
equilibrio menor que parece que está más
o menos a 40 centavos por galón y
tenemos
una nueva cantidad de equilibrio baja
qué es lo que sucede en este precio
obviamente la gente al corto plazo va a
querer producirla ya que aquí se
encuentra el costo marginal y como lo
hemos visto en varios vídeos anteriores
si hay alguien dispuesto a producir
siempre y cuando el costo sea igual al
costo marginal hoy son dispuestos a
producir una cantidad hasta que llegan
al punto en el que en el costo marginal
es igual al ingreso marginal como les
dije antes se necesitan 50 centavos para
tener una ganancia económica igual a
cero pero ahora en este caso parece que
necesitamos unos 40 centavos en donde
vamos a tener una pérdida económica así
que aquí no tenemos ganancia sin
ganancia y si no hay ganancia aquí pues
realmente no tiene sentido para ellos
continuar haciendo el jugo no tiene caso
para todos ellos seguir en este negocio
y lo que va a suceder es que conforme
pasa el tiempo aunque en el corto plazo
tenga sentido para ellos seguir
produciendo jugó porque ya tienen cierto
costo invertido ahí a lo mejor en equipo
o en personas contratadas pero conforme
pasa el tiempo con los precios tan bajos
conforme la gente vaya desgastando sus
equipos por ello no habrá ningún
incentivo para comprar equipo nuevo de
la misma manera conforme expiden los
contratos laborales
no va a haber un incentivo para renovar
esos contratos por lo que los negocios
van a ir cerrando y conforme estos
negocios van cerrando dos cosas van a
suceder la cantidad de producir en el
mercado va a bajar y el precio va a
subir y especialmente vamos a estar nos
moviendo a lo largo de esta curva hasta
que lleguemos a este punto en una
impresión de 50 centavos por galón de
nuevo y ahora la gente va estar en el
punto neutral no van a cerrar su negocio
así que vamos a llegar a este nuevo
punto de equilibrio el precio y cantidad
de equilibrio en el largo plazo y ahora
vamos a pensar en otra situación en
lugar de que salga un artículo diciendo
que el jugo de naranja es malo para la
salud ahora va a salir un artículo
diciendo que las naranjas son muy muy
buenas que es lo mejor de lo mejor que
pueden tomar bueno en ese caso en
cualquier precio la demanda va a
aumentar y la curva de demanda ahora va
a lucir así aquí tenemos un punto de
equilibrio más alto una cantidad de
equilibrio mayor y un precio de
equilibrio mayor ya que el precio de
venta está por encima del punto de
equilibrio las personas van a estar
haciendo ganancias lo que significa que
hay un gran incentivo para que las
personas continúen en este negocio ya
que están por encima del punto d
neutrales con respecto a si siguen o no
en ese negocio en ese punto muchas
personas van a estar muy motivadas para
entrar en el negocio lo que va a suceder
es que más y más gente va a estar
adquiriendo más y más equipo contratando
más y más personas y mientras lo hacen
la cantidad va a aumentar y por lo tanto
el precio va a bajar por lo que a largo
plazo nos vamos a deslizar hacia abajo
en esta curva hasta que lleguemos a este
punto en el cual no hay razón para que
más personas entren al negocio pues
estamos de nuevo en el punto neutral
lo que vemos suceder aquí es que en el
corto plazo vamos a ver en donde se
intersectan la curva de demanda y la
curva de la oferta pero a largo plazo
nos interesa ver en dónde se intersecta
con nuestra presión neutral con esta
línea horizontal el cual es el precio en
donde la ganancia económica es igual a
cero y es por eso que estamos aquí y una
forma más precisa de pensar en esto en
comparación de lo que hemos visto en los
vídeos anteriores es que esta línea
horizontal la pueden ver como la curva
de demanda a largo plazo curva de
demanda a largo plazo
y esto quiere decir que a largo plazo
nosotros vamos a producir cualquiera que
sea la oferta necesaria en el largo
plazo dado que la gente es neutral con
respecto a la ganancia económica
y llegamos aquí las personas tratarán de
usar sus costos fijos pero una vez que
los han gastado no hay incentivo para
permanecer allí algunos se saldrán del
negocio el precio aumentará la cantidad
disminuirá y regresaremos al punto de
nuestra curva de oferta a largo plazo y
lo mismo sucede en el lado opuesto mucha
ganancia económica muchas personas entra
en el mercado el precio baja la oferta
aumentan y regresamos a la curva de
oferta a largo plazo donde la nueva
curva de demanda intersecta a la curva
de oferta a largo plazo